well thank you very much for having me
and I want to describe an idea which
well it isn't all that new because it's
about 15 years old but I suppose that
counts as new I want to talk about
something which I claim happened before
the Big Bang now you see this represents
a change of mind on my part which used
to think like Stephen Hawking in many
people that the Big Bang didn't have any
before because the notion of before and
after didn't mean anything when there
wasn't a universe around and so you
couldn't even talk about before well I'm
going back on that and I claim that
there is something before but before
getting to that let me describe the
universe this is a picture which more or
less describes the history of the
universe as we understand it I need to
explain a couple of things about this
picture well first of all time is going
up and the Big Bang's down there and it
expands out slows down a bit and then it
starts starting to do this --tx what
they call the accelerated expansion that
seems to be taking place although there
was some dispute about that in the
earlier discussions I was involved in
but I'm taking the view visit is doing
this accelerated expansion now a couple
of things about this picture I just want
to show you that you could take sections
that represent one moment in time if you
like we imagine that blue plane sliding
up and the universe at any one moment is
considered to be that intersection
notice it looks like a line rather than
three-dimensional space you've got to
make allowances add a to add a couple of
dimensions to get the picture right so
this is really three dimensions and one
of times so that's the first thing I
want to explain about the picture the
second thing is what's all this frilly
stuff at the back doing well that's in
there because I don't want to prejudice
the issue as to whether the universe is
spatially open or closed these are nice
pictures of were due to MC Escher the
Dutch artist and here we have the closed
one you see you imagine space as being
the surface of that
again you've now got to throw away two
dimension so one dimension because it's
really a three dimensional version of
that that's the close case where the
curvature is positive this is the flat
case where it's Euclidean and this is
the case which is called negative
curvature I want to come back to this
picture later on because it's a
particular representation of this
geometry which is called hyperbolic
geometry where these angels and devils I
mean Escher is very cleverly use the
same creatures to illustrate these three
completely different geometries now the
current view is that it's more or less
flat but of course that means we don't
really know because we haven't seen the
whole thing it might curl round or I
might do this I'm not going to worry
about that the frilly stuff at the back
is just to say I'm not caring which it
is and I don't care what happens at the
back for at least for this discussion I
do care to a certain degree but that's
not the point now the next question is
what's all this at the beginning I've
there's the thing called inflation now
if you look at any modern cosmology book
whether it's popular or whether it's
technical they talk about within the
first ten to the minus thirty two
seconds that means one over the fraction
of a second that is which is something
thirty-two digits long ridiculously tiny
fraction of a second the universe was
supposed to have inflated now to get you
some picture of what inflation looks
like I'm putting a mountain powerful
magnifying glass here to have a good
look and what do we see
I should point out that we don't see
that that's the handle of the magnifying
glass but what you see is something very
similar let's back up to what you see in
the wrote future so it's it's sort of a
model of what's happening there but
tucked in at the beginning now you see
the reason I was not keen on mentioning
it here there's two reasons one is of
course it might be there tucked in and
that's why we need the magnifying glass
the other reason is I don't really
believe it so this is putting me in a
bad minority but I'm already in a
minority so that doesn't matter too much
so I'm trying to say I don't believe in
this but there are good reasons to
believe them let me say what's a
boundaries
first one of the reasons people put
forward is that you want to explain the
curious fact that the universe is really
very very uniform and this was one of
the explanations that somehow if it was
very irregular then this inflationary
phase will stretch it all out flat now I
never believed that argument and the
sort of reason is the following imagine
that the universe was collapsing so time
is not still going up but then there
will all be sorts of wrinkles there'll
be black holes and this picture now is
not I want to use another picture but I
couldn't find it so well don't you have
to imagine it a very very complicated
thing up there which doesn't look like
that not clean little point but a great
mess up there that's the sort of thing
you get when black holes you see this
fall black holes will form and they'll
congeal and make a huge mess and it
would look horrible not like that nice
point so why wasn't it like that the
other way around you see the equations
of Einstein work just as well in time
one way or the other way so why was it
not that huge mess at the beginning an
inflation doesn't solve that equation
that doesn't solve that problem but I
want to talk about that because this is
a key point of the argument and for the
moment I'm not going to say why I'm just
going to say what in a certain sense and
to do that it's useful to go back to the
Escher picture which I just showed you
and we now this is a spacial picture not
time in it so it's a space but these
angels and devils inhabit this infinite
universe so although it looks to us as
they're getting smaller and smaller to
the edge you have to imagine but you can
choose the angel of the devil whichever
you prefer that you are the same size no
matter how close to the edge you are
so these fellows or fellow asses no
matter where you are you will see it
looks just like the beginning and the
transformation involves here is what's
called conformal that is you squash down
in all directions by the same amount so
you're not just scratching this way but
you're squashing that by by the same
amount it's a very nice kind of geometry
angles like the angle on
wing of this devil will be the same no
matter how close to the edge you are the
eyes will be the same shape know how
close to the edge they're they're just a
different size so it's a it's a kind of
geometry very beautiful kind of geometry
well you're not interested in distances
but you're interested in in shape small
shape so if you like angles and this is
a very crucial part to the argument that
I want to give here so these angels as
Devils for their from their point of
view the universe is completely infinite
we look at it from a different
perspective we allow ourselves to squash
the infinity down in this conformal way
and you can imagine stepping from here
out to there they can't do it but you
can sort of imagine something might do
that
so let's come to that okay now I've now
applied this to the universe this was
the picture drawn smaller now of the
history of the universe keeps on going
out to infinity but that infinity like
in the angels and devils picture it
squashed down to this boundary here so
that represents the infinity of this
universe and that's quite accepted thing
you can do the universe as far as we
understand it in the very remote future
will smooth itself out in a way which
allows us to they're very general
theorem there's a theorem due to a
German helmet Friedrich who established
under very general circumstances this
conformal squashing down can be done so
there's no argument there what I'm doing
here on the beginning is the opposite
thing I'm stretching out the big bang to
make it look like a nice smooth surface
now that is not something which
generally happens it only happens when
the universe starts out very very
regular and smooth in the way we seem to
see it and there's a thing I used to
call the vile curvature hypothesis
nothing bothered to explain what that
means because it's a bit technical and
my former students and colleague Paul
Todd who had another way of saying it
what is it it says that the beginning of
the universe is conformally nice and
smooth so you can do this that's a
hypothesis if you adopt that hypothesis
you do get this universe which is sort
of smooth in the way we see and it's in
very important for this thing called the
second law of thermodynamics the second
law of thermodynamics says that this
thing called entropy which increases as
you go as time increases and thing is
that we see in the universe
observational ii but it looks as though
the entropy is very very high at the
beginning which should be very low
because it has to start low how is it
low it's low in gravity which means that
the universe with me i don't really want
to go into that argument shouldn't even
started early because it because it's
key to the description but it will
distract me too much for what I want to
say I just say there's good reason for
saying that this can be stretched out
it's very nice it solves a lot of
problems if that is the way the universe
for some reason stretched out like that
what's the reason well here's what I'm
saying the reason is is because this our
universe as we think of it starting from
the Big Bang ending up with this eternal
exponential expansion going on and on
and on getting you more and more borings
as time goes on and the argument is that
that our universes we serve as we
thought it's not the whole story that
this future remember the Escher picture
can be stretched squash down and now it
becomes the Big Bang of the next day on
and so this is what I call consort
conformal cyclic cosmology that we are
here there was one of these eons I'm
calling him a neo and I looked up in the
dictionary to make sure an eon aeo n was
not an actual length of time it seems to
be wrong it's a long time but not a
definite length of time which is fine by
me so I've used that term here a cosmic
Eon is that but I'm claiming there was a
cosmic eon preceding us one later than
the last one preceding before and so on
and they just continue indefinitely now
you see you might say well it's a bit
hard to swallow and that's what lots of
people say it's hard to swallow because
isn't the remote future very very
different from a Big Bang well first of
all it's very very rarefied it gets very
the density goes down and down
it's extremely cold the temperature goes
down and down and down what's the big
bang light density is huge the
temperature is enormous but you see when
you do this transformation which with
the I did with the angels and devils
that conform was squashing or stretching
it makes big tip when you stretch it
then big temperatures go down and the
densities go down when you squash it the
temperatures go up and the densities go
up and they match so they physically
match as well as geometrically matching
now there's one little catch to all this
to do with well I'll come to that in a
minute
before coming to that let me talk about
black holes
I did mention them before now this is a
picture of a black hole it's not the
normal thing where you see a black
splodge in the middle of something this
is a space-time picture so we have time
going up there and this is matter
collapsing down and this thing here is
the horizon so I have time one dimension
and I managed to get sort of two
dimensions of space in grey there's
another one but I only stive got two in
imagining going round and round like
that and that is the picture of a black
hole it's pretty good picture really
that now the point about the picture are
these cones now one of those cones doing
I have to talk about the cones they're
really important now here is what's
called a light cone or a null cone you
have to imagine in the space-time
four-dimensional thing at any point
there is one of these cones sitting
there now what does that cone tell you
it tells you what light does so you
imagine there's a flash of light at that
point and it's time progresses it
spreads up this is a special picture now
I can get all the dimensions in if you
like here I have to imagine the cone
it's got another dimension but you think
of it as a surface but these sections
through the cone represent the history
of a flash of light in the middle
spanning out expanding out so we have
the red one and then the blue one and
the red one represents this section for
the cone and the blue one that section
and here we can have all two dimensions
of the surface so that's it's three
dimensional together and here we have
only one so that's a good picture of
what a light cone is doing so a flash of
light there would spread out and you'd
have imagining
special terms that things spreading out
as a light flash would do what about the
pass comb well that you imagine a flash
of light coming in and converging on
that point it's a very useful concept to
have in space-time because it tells you
causality you see things which can
affect other things are always within or
on the cone and outside is you can't
influence that so this is and this is
special relativity where these cones are
all uniformly arranged this is general
relativity where they can wobble around
in various ways and the picture of jet
this is a sort of illustration of what
can happen in general ativy the cones
are not uniformly there but you can see
that information from inside can't
escape because it would have to cross
across the cone and remaining within the
cone you can't do because the cones
pointing in so that's why light and any
kind of matter is trapped inside this
horizon so these things you can
understand nicely by looking at that
picture and thinking a lot about it and
here's the material before it collapses
and then things can get out there but
the horizon is where the cones are
tipped in and even going as the speed of
light you can't escape from within it
okay so that's this general picture now
what's that well you see this is this
sort of causal structure of the light
cone structure or what can influence
what structure of space-time but there's
one more to it I should say there's a
thing called the metric in general
relativity which has its described by
ten numbers and those ten numbers nine
of them roughly speaking tell you where
these cones are and the tenths one is
telling you what these surfaces in here
let me explain what they are they are
what clocks do you see here I have a
couple of clocks zipping along and their
clocks according to relativity they
don't keep a sort of universal time
that's one of the difficult things to
understand but different clocks moving
in different ways have their own time
and you've imagined these are identical
clocks and this surface room meant many
describes the first tick of the clock
that the second tickin in the third tick
and so on so when you have these little
bowl-shaped services arranged inside the
cone that gives you the passage of time
for regard to clocks and that gives you
the tenth component so really it's the
nine of the ratios of the ten but don't
worry about that so I should say the
cones give you most of the information
the rest of the information you need are
these services now key thing about this
is that things which travel the speed of
light don't even notice those services
so light itself travels along here it
doesn't care about those services the
key thing is math you see they're the
two most important formulae of famous
formulae of 20th century physics were
Einsteins e equals mc-squared that tells
you energy and mass are equivalent
Max Planck even before Einstein had
equals and it was H nu H is a constant
and E and nu is the frequency this tells
you energy and frequency equivalent put
the two together that tells you mass and
frequency are equivalent so if you have
a particle of a certain mass it has a
frequency it has a normal pass and be
very very high frequency but it's one of
the reasons we have very very precise
clocks in nature ultimately because of
this but it depends on mass that's the
point I want to say if you have mass you
have clocks if you don't have mass you
don't have clocks and the equations of
Maxwell which tell you how
electromagnetism works they're
completely invariant under squatch enos
stretch stretching so they're angels and
devils that it wouldn't they wouldn't
know how big they were if they just had
electromagnetism to control how they
work so things with mass are needed to
give you the scale so this is the
crucial point of this description the
idea here is that you don't really have
mass here or here why don't you have
mass here when you see what's the most
dominant can't well they've got a lot of
mass around here but with black holes
around they swallow most of it up and if
you have huge black holes and galactic
clusters they swallow each other up and
eventually they start swallowing the
cluster up and they probably swallow
most of it up
most of the stuff running around will be
photons they don't have any mass so
that's the argument for here if it's
just photons running around then this
you don't care about them you can squash
things down like in the azure picture so
that's a key point i mean maybe you've
got some rogue or electrons running
around but then I have an argument why
the mass should fade out there but let's
not go into that that's too a bit too
technical but going back in the other
way
surely you've got lots of mass well you
see particles you've got massive
particles yes but when they get hotter
and hotter and hotter they move faster
and faster and faster and that means me
almost the entire mass is in their
energy and sands e equals MC squared so
that the mass becomes completely
irrelevant and the closer you get to
that point again mass becomes irrelevant
so this is the key part of the argument
mass becomes irrelevant or isn't they're
both here and here and so the squashing
and stretching is physically sensible
now that takes a bit of swallowing and
many of my colleagues in cosmology I may
say have a lot of trouble swallowing it
and I'm hoping since you're not most of
you cosmologists you probably have an
easier time to swallow it when they do
but let me go on this is the conformal
structure where you don't have mass
that's fine that's all the non mass
things need to know this is when you do
have mass okay now this was what I was
just saying about the clocks now what
about the black holes well first of all
there they are I put the black holes in
the picture these these are represented
by these red lines something they
swallow each other and so on and there
are the red lines on the picture but
according to Stephen Hawking and yes I
agree with him I mean I didn't know it
before he says it but you have a black
holes radiate so they're not completely
black he says they're a little bit cold
I'm an extremely coalition say but not
zero temperature they have a
ridiculously small temperature certainly
for the black holes we know are out
there ridiculously small but in general
but okay when the universe expands and
expands and expands the black holes
become the hottest things around when
they are they radiate away energy
and radiated where energy and radiate
away until they finally disappear with
what I'm calling a pop pretty small
compared with the energy in the whole
thing ridiculously small how long does
that take
well for the biggest ones even it may be
an understatement
but the biggest ones you would have to
wait something like a Google years now
what's a Google 1 0 0 or 100 zeros years
that's the sort of length of time you
have to wait in fact that's what started
without for this whole argument I
thought how boring this universe is
going to be and when there's nothing but
black holes that pretty boring but to
wait for this blasted thing to go off
for Google yes even that's not the
boring thing it's when they're gone
that's boring this incredible eternity
of nothing ok that's an emotional
argument I agree but nevertheless it was
some driving force and I thought well
who's gonna be bored by this not us how
about photons than many photons and it's
pretty hard to bore a photon because not
just because they probably don't have
experiences ok I'll give you that but
because according to relativity they
don't have the passage of time from
creation to the infinities nothing they
get ran out to infinity and there they
are so that was the sort of reason I was
introducing these ideas ok the black
holes go away like this they're there
they're gonna pop this is not everything
I've said in these pictures up to this
point it's pretty well to scale this is
not to scale this is way up there
somewhere really a golf pop not even up
there and right up the edge of the
universe even that's isn't good enough
so it's a long way off okay so so they
disappear pop now I'm going to tell you
see I thought when I'd had these various
ideas I could go on lecturing about this
forever because nobody will ever know
whether it's right or not and so I
thought but then I had a rather
uncomfortable foot when you see I
mentioned these black holes we have a as
I think I didn't say yet but I'll sit in
that centre of our galaxy a black hole
which has a mass of about 4 million
times the mass of the Sun pretty big
we are on a collision course with the
Andromeda galaxy
now the andromeda galaxy has a black
hole in it which is about 40 times i
think the size of us pretty much bigger
than ours in about a few thousand
million years we're gonna collide we're
on a collision course as I said and and
I don't know how many years later the
black holes will feel each other out
spiral each other around and kaboom they
will run into each other kaboom isn't
the good description because it's not a
sound its gravitational waves and you
can't hear gravitational waves
nevertheless those signals will go out
and reach the Infinity this is the what
I call a crossover surface between one
Eon and the next it should be really
three-dimensional but I've drawn it two
dimensional I hope that's all right now
this is meant to be ass up here there's
us and we're looking back that's our
past light cone and this is the Big Bang
or the cross over from the previous Eon
to us now here we have a couple of
collisions in a cluster bang and another
bang and they create quite a ring here
and according to the equations what you
find is that these signals should
influence the dark matter in the next
Eon and you should be able to see
signals and so the claim is that you
would and they will be rather faint
they'll be faint signals either slightly
warmer than average or slightly cool
it's a bit of a nuisance because of
alternatives but there's slightly more
uniform around the ring but normal and I
have a colleague and Armenian colleague
via Gossage on who started look for
these things and a key thing is that if
this happened several times as they will
in a cluster of galaxies you will have
several of these bangs and they will be
centered at the same point so this is a
key thing so I asked them can you see
rings like this which are centered at
the same point he came up with pictures
like this this is the picture of the
whole sky and what we're looking at is
the microwave background so this is this
radiation coming from all directions
it's very slight variations in
temperature there's a slight one of the
variations temperatures due to the
Earth's motion because we're moving
through this radiation and you have to
correct for that first
when you correct for that you find a
very uniform distribution of the sky
uniform - about one part in 100,000 so
one part one hundred one thousand it's
this temperature is the same but little
variations in this is what we're looking
at and what via was looking for are
these concentric rings of temperature
which is more uniform over the ring than
he comes up with pictures like this and
I thought I was expecting to see a
pretty uniform distribution over the sky
for to see anything at all and that's
what he saw this was the W map satellite
which which is a satellite which went
around I don't how many years ago and
pretty good and it showed what these
temperature variations of the sky more
recently another satellite we the Planck
satellite and he did it again for this
and again you see these crowding of
these things but let me go to see
there's a picture of the centers and I
thought that doesn't look random to me
the claim is we're looking through into
the eon prior to ours and we're looking
at clusters of galaxies so each point
here would represent a cluster of
galaxies in that previous Eon clustered
the clusters are clustered in the
previous Eon so they should be clustered
in Arion so one of the claims here is
that there's a lot more clustering well
eastern the eon prior to ours and people
seem to think which that may be the case
what are the colors well that's another
independent thing the colored ones the
red ones are the nearer ones the blue
ones are the more distant ones so again
that's clustering because the red ones
are all together and the blue ones are
together and the greenish ones are sort
of in between pretty good evidence
there's something there and I claim this
is and some polish colleagues of mine
had a look and using completely
different methods they also find a
significant signal that these rings are
there are now not thinking about
colliding black holes and thinking about
the black holes themselves and this is
their Hawking of aberration so this is
the black hole and it vibrates away
right up here you see google here is his
way up tucked up here this is the
bang this is what's called the last
scattering surface that's what you
actually see and the signal spreads out
like this the claim that's the claim do
you see these this would be a slight
raising of temperature from here to here
would be about eight times the moon's
diameter so what would be a spot here
goes up to eight times the damage of the
moon do you see things like that in the
guy
well Christoph Meisner and my other
colleagues I should say this is just the
what's called the power spectrum you've
got to put this in in order to see
something is significant this is that
what you see now you see what you do is
you take this if you think of the
universe is like a balloon and you think
it vibrating in all sorts of ways
whether it sort of noise the frequency
it vibrates is if you like the power
here don't worry about what that picture
is exists if you're a cosmologists you
say worry about that a lot more but the
point is that you have to put this in
and with what you see the observed power
spectrum you're then allowed to vary how
the different ways in which that balloon
can oscillate vibrates and things like
that so that's what that's what they do
and they make you make maybe a thousand
fake skies which have the same picture
as this but in detail they can can vary
as much as you like so that's the idea
and our colleague Daniel Anne who is a
Korean who work works in New York and he
did this he looked at the thousand
simulations what we're looking at as
little rings like this and these are
different sizes for the inner ring and
the other thing what they look as the
temperature change from here to here so
if you're looking back it's something
where the temperature goes up in the
middle then the this would be warmer
than that is the idea and how much
warmer is that than that well is it is
it anomalous is its average is that what
you'd expect you look at the power
spectrum look at all these random fake
skies and 4,000 fakes guys who finds
zero that is to say all these other
numbers are the sorts of things you find
for rings which are all the wrong shape
and size for that for that signal when
you hit it dead on you see none
of the fake skies show this phenomena
that means it's really significant this
is even quite significance the number is
quite small here any sort of well that's
it's it's here is about six isn't it
okay people complain oh there's what
your call and look elsewhere effect let
me go into that you were looking only
you after you saw the evidence and so
the problem but it is so Daniel did it
again 9,000 more simulations what
happened to these zeros when this woman
comes to this one becomes one
ridiculously smaller than anything else
it's a real thing what in terms of
probabilities what does it mean it means
that the thing the chance of this being
a random effect is well the chancellery
being real as opposed to random is
99.98% confidence that's what you get
from these figures so it's really there
and it seems to be there and what else
can you explain well I think that's the
end of mine yeah let's not go into that
that's I don't have time to go into that
but if people want to ask me that's fine
thank you very much
[Applause]